est-ce que vous voulez bien me dire
pourquoi vous prenez votre voiture au
lieu de prendre un autobus ou un train
pour vous rendre à
[Musique]
Paris
7h du matin dans une gare de
banlieu une marée humaine défer le vers
Paris
madame vous prenez régulièrement le
train pour vous rendre à Paris oui vers
quelle heure à peu près 8h21 8h36 quand
je suis en retard vous ne prenez qu'un
seul moyen de transport ou vous changez
sin non je prends le métro aussi et je
vais du côté d'Alem et je vais à pied à
saint-lazar à Saint-Augustin je prends
assez souvent le train pour aller à mon
bureau
que c'est pra votre bureau est à côté de
la G 10 minutes à pied minutire minutes
àed ah oui bien sûr ça fait un peu
d'exerci vous prenez qu'un seul moyen de
transport vous en avez plusieurs le
métro le train et ensuite le
métro et vous la laiss à la gare
pourquoi abandonnezvous votre voiture
jeabandonne parce que je l'utilise pas
pour aller à Paris parce que c'est plus
long que par le train avant je prends
suis pédestre et après je prends le
métro en général TR je prend TR laare
saint-lazar jusqu'àargenteuil là j'ai
une correspondance qui me descend à
saintis et de là je prends un autobus
donc vouses try de transport ày de
transport une correspondance de train
vous prenez d'autres moyens de transport
non pas du tout
non ce qui marque avant tout cette ruée
vers Paris c'est signe de notre temps
une course perpétuelle contre la
montre
combien de temps à peu près le voyage ça
fait à peu près une à peu près enfin tr/
d'heure je mets pas beaucoup de temps je
mets 30 bons je pars du bureau à 6h
j'arrive chez moi j'avite plusutôt
j'arrive chez moi à 7h alors minimum 1
heure et maximum 1 he de s'il faut
attendre les autobus en principe je mets
50 minutes de porte à porte par le train
le métro et en voiture entre 1h et 2h à
peu près selon les
heures et parce que vous êtes chaque
année plus nombreux dans cette course
vers Paris il a été nécessaire d'adapter
des techniques nouvelles aux impératifs
du trafic en voici un exemple avec le
nouveau prs de saint-lazar poste tout
relais à transit souple c'est votre
sécurité qui
l'assure jugez-en par ces chiffres 70000
passagers aux heures creuses 200000 aux
heures de
pointe au total 65000 km parcourus
chaque jour par 3000 trains de
lie qui transporte 1200000 passagers par
jour mais tous n'arrivent pas en même
temps si aux heures de pointe les trains
se succèdent à moins de 5 minutes
d'intervalle pour déverser 200000
passagers à l'heure il incombe aussi à
la SNCF d'assurer un service régulier
aux heures
creuses cela veut dire utilisation
permanente du personnel du
matériel rentabilité moins grande avec
pour conséquence le déficit ce sont les
obligations du service public les quais
sont déserts mais les trains roulent
quand
[Musique]
même qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de ce
moyen de transport C assez pratique
évidemment mais
il y a il faudit plus de trains beaucoup
plus de trains on est toujours
debout je trouve que il y a trop d'arrê
jusqu'à Paris ilit les trains
parisvsaill direct ben mon Dieu
évidemment au he d'inffluence on est un
petit peu tassé mais enfin autrement ça
va en espace d'un heure tout le monde
reprend le train et c'est vraiment la
grosse bousculade le matin c'est un peu
plus dilevé oh al là c'est très très
très moche pourquoi pas de train un
temps infini pour rentrer c'est vraiment
déplorable surtout sur la Gard de l'Est
mais quand vous rentrez le soir si vous
sortez le soir par exemple ah là je suis
obligé de reprendre ma voiture pour
sortir le soir et si vous NZ pas prise
qu'est-ce que vous fait si je l'ai pas
pris je demande à ma femme qui conduit
de venir me chercher au bureau quels
sont les autres avantages que vous y
trouvez question de confort lire mon
journal écoutez je trouve tout même pas
désagréable pourquoi parce que moi je
sais pas ça fait au fond une demi-heure
de détente le matin on se repose le soir
également plus rapide que qu'avec la
voiture avec les
d'abord il y a pas pas d'ennui à garer
sa voiture toutes les heures et demi et
puis c'est plus rapide on gagne
énormément de temps et ils sont encore
très nombreux ces partisans de
l'automobile malgré toutes les
difficultés toutes les embuches qu'ils
rencontrent sur leur
route malgré tous les moyens de
dissuasion mise en œuvre pour les
pousser à laisser leur voiture au garage
devant une garde banlieu ou au moins aux
portes de
[Musique]
Paris malgré le prix de relevien élevé
de ce moyen de transport et les aléas
qui peuvent encore l'augmenté
[Musique]
considérablement
pouvez-vous me dire pourquoi vous prenez
votre voiture au lieu de prendre un
métro ou un autobus et bien je prends ma
voiture et je m'en vais actuellement à
l'hôpital broussé alors je comme il y a
pas beaucoup de moyens de transport pour
la broussé je suisé de prendre ma
voiture pour mon travail oui mais
pourquoi vous prenez pas un métro ou un
train écoutez je je suis dans le
bâtiment je fais les chantiers alors ce
sera impossible de faire tout ce que
j'ai à faire dans la journée avec le ah
oui parce que vous déplacez beaucoup
continuellement oui c'est ça parce que
les transports en commun et bien en
principe il y a pas assez de véhicule et
ils sont jamais à l'heure pourant vous
êtes dans une région bien desservie ou
peut-être ici mais comme j'habite
Brunois c'est complètement différent
c'est parce que moi j'habite pas
tellement loin et je n'ai pas besoin de
rentrer dans Paris remarque je prends ma
voiture que pour des petits parcours et
pour les grands parcours je prends le
métro je vais savoir ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun et pourquoi
vous ne les prenez pas je ne les prends
pas pour la bonne raison que j'habite le
Brésil mademoiselle la liberté de
personnel c'est c'est beaucoup on a une
voiture bien fait pour s'en servir
est-ce que vous voulez bien me dire
pourquoi vous prenez votre voit au lieu
de prendre un autobus ou un train pour
vous rendre à
Paris en effet dans la majorité des cas
le transport ne se limite pas au seul
chemin de fer l'habitant de la région
parisienne utilise aussi l'autobus de
banlieu et le métro il se joint alors à
la masse des Parisiens par des chiffres
nous allons également voir à quel point
les responsabl de la RATP ont à faire
face à des problèmes complexes d'horair
de matériel et de
personnel en un an ce sont 1ard millions
de voyageurs qui ont pris le métro au
heur de pointe 700000 voyageurs à
l'heure et seulement 120000 aux heures
creuses au total pour le métro 4
millions de voyageurs par jour qui font
380000 km sous terre au moyen de 555
rames effectuant 6000 départs par
jour des chiffres
[Musique]
considérable d'autres chiffres
concernant les
autobus 1 million de passagers par jour
dans Paris qui utilise 1257 autobus et
parcour 330000
[Musique]
km on compte 1500000 passagers par jour
en banlieu
[Musique]
monsieur vous prenez très souvent le
métro tous les jours ça fait 40 ans ça
fait 40 ans et bien oui ça m'arrive
aujourd'hui c'est un peu exceptionnel
c'est parce que ma voiture est en panne
alors vous nêtes pas un habitué si quand
même si si pour aller dans Paris je
trouve que c'est un moyen assez commode
vous n'avez pas de voiture si alors
pourquoi vous prenez le métro parce que
dans Paris je peux pas stationner
aujourd'hui ça fait drôle de voir tant
de monde c'est plutôt vers les 6h 7h
qu'il y a du monde
et qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce moyen
de
transport vraiment trop tracé bien
justement c'est agréable c'est de
circuler aux heures non de
pointesouand quand peut pas faire
autrement ça me paraî assezolant on
voyage plutôt mal faut dire beaucoup
trop de monde et point de vue chaleur
pas si assz quand même puisque on est
serré surtout dans le métro alors qus
sont les avantage du métro pour vous
avant une relative rapidité de transport
si vous avz une voiture vous prendz le
méro ah toujours le métro je pense quand
même que c'est le métro le plus commode
mieux que l'autobus l'autobus est plus
agréable mais les embouteillages donnent
du retard ces retards restent le gros
handicap des autobus malgré les couloirs
réservés leur priorité sur les autres
véhicules et le centre de régulation qui
surveille leur
[Musique]
parcours pour but de confort alors
impossible de lire pourquoi parce que
nous sommes trois secouer nous les deux
fois les mêmes
choses point de vue
lumière l'éclairage est mauvais
soir point de vue promuscuité c'est
parfois
[Musique]
déplaisant vous venez de le manquer hein
oui je viens de le manquer de très peu
mais enfin tant pis ça sera sera le
brochain vous prenez souvent l'autobus
euh je le prends tous les jours mais pas
sur cette banlieu là parce que j'habite
la banlieue sud-est qu'est-ce que vous
préférez en général comme moyen de
transport en commun j'ends le métro
parce que là on est sûr d'arriver à
l'heure et qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
autres moyens de transport quels sont
vos critiques si vous les prenez souvent
euh et bien on est trop bousculé aux
heures de pointe ça évidemment les
arrêts qui ne sont pas aménager pour
mettre à l'abri les les usagers des
intempéries et avec les grands ensembles
qui se créent peu partout ben je crois
que les transports ne sont pas encore au
point vous avez des enfants oui j'ai une
fille et un garçon et eux comment se
rendent-ils à leur collège et bien le
garçon va à pied parce que c'est assez
près mais la fille a des problèmes de
transport a été affecté au lycée à
l'annexe de créteille qui est assez loin
de la maison le l'annexe qui est mal
desservi par les autobus et je crois que
même les enfants qui habitent à
créteille près du grand ensemble de
montmell ne sont pas gâtés au point de
vue moy yen de transport alors comment
font-ils et bien ils vont la plus pour
la plupart en vélo il y a un énorme
parking à vélo qui est à l'entrée du
lycée nous ne remonterons pas autant des
carrosses à saint-sol premier véhicule
du transport en commun pour les
parisiens mais simplement à l'époque où
se creusèrent les premiers souterrains
du Métropolitain qui fut une véritable
révolution des transports
[Musique]
parisiens 1900 la première ligne Vincen
maillot était ouverte à l'exploitation
les trains étaient formés de trois
voitures en bois et circulaient à la
vitesse de 20 km à l'heure le réseau ne
cessa de s'étendre pour atteindre 178 km
en 1941 date à laquelle il fut mis en
sommeil par les
événements les premiers trains de
banlieu eux apparurent un siècle plus
tôt c'est en août 1837 que fut mise en
service la première de ces lignes par
Paris Saint-Germain en lait longue de 17
km l'attraction à vapeur a depuis ces 20
dernières années presque complètement
disparu l'électrification des lignes
s'est faite dans presque toute la région
parisienne à l'exception de quelques
lignes où elle va être entreprise très
prochainement en effet l'évolution des
transports en commun risquait de se
laisser prendre de vitesse par
l'augmentation démographique
considérable et le développement rapide
de la région
parisienne
[Musique]
l'implantation des grands ensembles et
des cités d'ortoir tout autour de la
capitale l'migration quotidienne de
cette population active qui le matin se
rent à Paris et le soir regagne son
domicile ont nécessité
l'extension de nouveaux autobus sont
lancés sur des parcours nouveaux il faut
simultanément rénover et augmenter le
parc de voiture l'aggravation de la
circulation nécessite 60 véhicules
supplémentaires par an et au total la
RATP met en service 400 autobus neuf
chaque année ces autobus à grande
capacité représentent maintenant 24 % du
parc petit à petit l'ancien matériel est
remplacé par des voitures plus
confortables moins bruyantes plus
rapides voici le bilan des efforts
réalisés tels que l'exigeit la mutation
de la région par
mais sont-ils
[Musique]
suffisants